welcome back to new rockstars this is a
big question the show that gives you too
much information about how when avengers
start hanging out with the wrong people
they can really
fall into witchcraft if they're not
careful
is one division set enough one a maximum
for a wizard duel with dr strange and
who would win that fight
i'm eric voss here making the magic
happen with joshua openshire aka
jovan hey man making the magic happen
how
on point in thematic very glad to be
here
and we're so glad to have you here you
are working on some very exciting stuff
and uh i want you to tell us about it
yeah that's right thank you for having
me on i get to talk about my new show i
got the logo back there on a chair
uh i did a show called stuff of legends
which is a
d and d it's an official dungeons and
dragon show with wizards of the coast
and it is a cast of actors and comedians
playing d d for the first time but all
of the action and all the dialogue
is all redone as puppets kind of like
drunk history but
yeah meets the muppets in d so that's
going to be on youtube.com
the jovenshire for the next six weeks uh
as of february 2nd the first episode is
officially up so go check it out
on my youtube go check it out go check
it out
uh i believe you can go see it uh well
that sounds very exciting i
love d d and i love puppets it's the
best worlds it's like why not puppets
it's fun it's it's like playing with
cartoons but with like physical comedy
attached to them so yes why not puppets
why not puppets
marvel movie all puppets i mean yeah oh
uh
that might be an episode of juan
division for all we know they might skew
right into sesame
i'm into it well one division is really
showing us the dark side of scarlet
which is magic
but also a much more specific depiction
of her sorcery than really we've ever
seen in the mcu
magic in general in the marvel world is
uh very much a pandora's box we don't
really know how it works looks like in
real life
we don't know how magic works i got my
phone you david copperfield i'll figure
it out eventually
his hands just move too fast so our big
question for today comes to us from
a cokey2 off of discord and he asks all
the different forms of
magic in the mcu doctor strange wanda
even ebony ma
how are they different and which is the
most powerful
and what are their sources very very
good question
uh so let's talk about how one of
maximoff's magic
works exactly and how it compares to
these other forms of magic we've seen in
the mcu
does magic all come from the same place
in the mcu does it come from other
places and if so is that weird um maybe
maybe but that's a question for kevin
feige we'll do our best
starting with wanda her magic is what is
called chaos magic
also sometimes called hex magic in the
comics it comes from the demon called
chathan or kathon
he cursed wanda at a young age and her
magic
is kind of unique to her it is believed
that this magic is connected to the dark
hole that's the ancient marvel spell
book the book of the dead
but in terms of its uh aesthetic
qualities it's meant to be supernatural
akin to the world of witchcraft and
demonology vampires werewolf zombies all
that all that great stuff all the good
stuff we want in our marvel uh she's a
witch
scarlet witch it's meant to be kind of
associated with that
um but she's also an omega level mutant
and that puts her up there with like
phoenix in terms of her god level
abilities she can kind of rewrite
reality now in the mcu
in the movies and in one of vision
wanda's magic uh
also comes from another source that were
for the our purposes are going to call
cosmic magic basically just means the
infinity stones
which i i will say that yes her magics
were
activate her magic was activated by the
stone but it could kind of be
now that they have the the mutants with
uh fox and everything
they could easily kind of rewrite what
they've been doing and much like
deadpool needed to go through a
traumatic experience for his uh
gene to be activated maybe it was just
the mind stone that
activated her mutant gene in order to
start to spark some of these
these spells and we talked about you
know uh like the hex magic and chaos
magic
and that theoretically still can be
explained and
worked into the mcu with how her magic
is
is utilized it might not just be a comic
thing anymore
right right um they could they could
completely redefine things now and it
seems like you know one division is
going back to sokovia we've seen that in
trailer footage by the time you're
watching this you may have already seen
what that episode's going to be
uh whatever it is but yeah it's going
back to strucker
and that hydra lab at sokovia but i
think
when it comes to a relationship with
vision the mind stone is that kind of
link
it's kind of what binds them together is
the fact that her powers are seen to be
activated by the mind stone he's powered
by the mind stone
and that's kind of what one division all
is right
in fact there's even a call out in
episode two where that cabinet of
mysteries and their magic trick
is uh that pattern looks like the mind
stone in vision's head and leave it to
the new rock stars to
find that logo right there for everyone
so hey we find it now i did not call it
out in my breakdown of episodes yeah
there's a lot of stuff a lot of stuff
there's a lot in the series yeah
um now just to better define what cosmic
magic is
you remember in infinity war when thanos
and doctor strange had that wizard duel
that was all because of cosmic magic
uh doctor strange has his own kind of
magic that we'll talk about but
the fact that thanos could keep up with
him blow for blow
create black holes and and shape-shift
stuff and and
move the ground around that that all
came from the powers the magic of the
cosmos
specifically channeled through the space
stone the reality stone the power stone
and the soul stone which are the four
that he had at that moment
when you mentioned like the uh the
wizard duel at the top of the episode i
just
you you immediately go back to the sword
and the stone
wizard duel and the disney animated
feature now i just want that now i just
want
you know doctor strange going against
scarlet witch and they're just turning
each other into animals and monsters
that's great and when we talk about
wanda's magic
it does allow her to warp reality and it
appears in one of vision brainwashed
everyone within that reality into
believing it's just their
normal world that's what we saw in house
of m as well but
uh that magic while extremely powerful
is not something that wanda is yet
entirely in control of
which is a very very key distinction
doesn't matter how powerful your power
is if you don't know how to use it then
how powerful does that make you
well would that also be in question to
the type of magic it is because it's
chaos magic it is based off of like
probability control uh
she might not be able to control it
because it is just a
around like the probabilities around her
so
there is no way to control it but it's
almost like domino's like
uh luck sp uh uh you know special heroic
ability where
you know i think in the comics scott
which even was used her magic just to uh
destroy a pipeline underneath her
enemies because it was like oops that
was the thing that happened
probability control right or to put it
in terms of pokemon moves
thrash while a wildly devastating move
often misses and so how powerful how
good of a move really is that
you only need one to hit that's true um
so let's move on to talk about doctor
strange
dr strange is also a wizard very capable
magic practitioner but his magic comes
from a different place from the mystic
arts under the sorcerer's supreme and
the term for it is eldritch magic so
you know something is eldritch magic if
it's sparkly
if you see these kind of golden sparkles
a little call back to uh the d and d
reference here a little uh eldrick blast
for my warlocks at home
what's up
[Music]
um now it uh does uh it's pretty useful
eldritch magic it
can create these teleportation portals
uh it can be used to create
uh protection spells weapons illusions
telekinesis you can move stuff around
but it's this very ancient kind of magic
but um
in the mcu and this might just be true
for doctor strange and no movie that
comes after
it seems like anyone can kind of tap
into it there's that dude uh benjamin
bratt's character jonathan pangborn
he used it to heal his body and it's
like okay so if anybody just wanders
into commerce and commits to this they
can kind of tap into this eldritch magic
which also
what he healed himself and he's like all
right that's good enough i don't need to
know the
mysteries of the unknown anymore i want
to play basketball with my buddies and
be able to walk over to joe's and get a
slice
now uh dr strange is different though
he has a photographic memory very high
intelligent
uh person and that allows him to master
these arts quickly and at a level few
others can
so he kind of has like a natural super
ability in that regard
so while there are many sorcerers dr
strange has more of a mastery over those
skills
and gives him more control over
navigating the multiverse
that's why he is the sorcerer supreme
because no one can compete
and and not only that there was that
line and end game where the ancient one
says he was going to be the best of
us like he's almost kind of destined to
be this uh he's made for this job you
are the chosen one
exactly um now there is another type of
sorcerer magic that the sorcerers use
that is specifically from the dark
dimension this is different from
eldritch magic
because the dark dimension magic gives
you the power over kind of the mechanics
of the universe it's almost cosmic in a
way
because you can manipulate time uh the
dormammu is
uh well i don't know if dormammu can
manipulate time he's just kind of
timeless in a way
he's timeless uh and can suffer from
time so if he can control time i don't
think doctor strange would have been
able to uh
beat him the way he did exactly so this
dark dimension magic must be
weaker than cosmic magic and because the
time stone trumped it in that final
battle
but uh this magic allows you to
manipulate uh gravity
um the way things can kind of re-piece
around you reality
because the way that the ancient one
stopped that whole
um bendy uh mirror dimension battle
is uh she she kind of pieced everything
around using pieces of the city of new
york and had that symbol on her head
and the kaiselius called her a hypocrite
when she did that
so um that means that there is like a
cosmic component to it but it's not the
same thing as cosmic magic and not as
powerful
i wonder if it's kind of like you know
with
with us we've got our you know the four
elements right and i wonder if like this
all of the different magics technically
just pull from these different cosmic
stones
and this could be their trace and origin
yeah uh that is possible i think that's
kind of a recurring
element is at least so far throughout
the infinity saga a lot of things can be
traced back to the infinity stones
if you do a couple whips to get there
um and another example of that is
another form of magic that we've seen in
the mcu
the asgardian magic that's what we see
from the people
in the world of thor um that's used on
asgard
and other realms outside of midgard um
so like asgardian magic is what powers
the bifrost
it comes from the all fathers um you
could say that's what allows heimdall to
see
souls wherever they are in the universe
frigga that's thor's mom
she's a witch oh that's right that uh
she can kind of see the future
so that uh it comes from a magical place
um
odin's worthiness charm of course hey
that's a form of escorting magic i'm
sure we're gonna talk about it but uh
he does mention that the asgardian magic
isn't necessarily it's
science where they come from so i wonder
if if that same
logic can be applied to the other magics
as well
it doesn't seem like the ancient one
refers to it as
a science it's something that you can
teach and it can be replicated
thus perhaps still a science um but the
way that the asgardians
see their magic as science i wonder if
that actually does put it in a
different uh like box yeah you know the
asgardians are
like uh millennia old they're like 5 000
years old they're millennials
yes yes classic so
moody and aimless and just let it all
burn just thor eating his avocado toast
letting apple bees go out of business
yeah
um but like they view it as science and
in my opinion
viewing it as science kind of weakens
the you know
the whole magical side of it is it's a
technology
as opposed to magic but isn't that such
a human way to look at it
it takes the excitement out of it
because it's science yeah
humans are weak i want ghosts ghosts
can't kill
the the fact that they call it science
uh i think is kind of a link back to
cosmic magic to the infinity stones
which is a form of technology you know
the tester act
was a technological outgrowth of the
space stone
it allowed people to use it in in a very
specific way and what is technology
if not um being's ability to build
something
to harness some kind of uh the element
of the universe
i think we just came up with a new
definition of technology oh yeah they're
right look at you
and look at that look at us a wheel is
just using gravity in an interesting way
uh yeah um but oh we should also call
loki loki
is a frost giant or you know he's like
frost yeah he's uh but he has a kind of
magic he can
you know shape shift he can project
himself you can
dance i don't know where yeah yeah
that's all comes from that place
um so i think you know other than that
asgardian magic isn't explored too
deeply in the mcu
uh there's only a couple mentions they
mentioned the all fathers a couple of
times
it's actually kind of religious in
origin you know it's kind of like the
heart-shaped herb of wakanda it's like a
spiritual magic
but it's not saying that these people
are wizards yeah uh it but it is
because there was the deleted scene from
ragnarok
where odin was going to talk to thor
about you know the the all father
being then put into thor which i think
would have given
that magic a different spin in that
world if that was how it was explained
because then it was more of like an
essence that something that could be
passed along versus something that it's
created from a tool the thing about
asgard though is because it's so ancient
because it has those ties with the
infinity stones the tesseract the ether
it almost suggests that their magic
comes from those stones like
the bifrost and the tesseract the space
stone are kind of the same thing
are they not like they allow you to
teleport open up portals
who's to say that the power of the
bifrost did not come from the tesseract
itself
to me that makes sense you take this one
element like you're
that is so strong that just by
manipulating can expand and create
whatever you need it to
if it goes back that far and that's how
they created their asgard
now people ask about ebony mom it was an
interesting one
uh his he's magical he's so magical
when you look into his eyes he's just
you get lost in those i don't know what
this
is but it's kind of hot um he
gets his magic from an unknown source um
like he's
the issue with him he's a relatively
recent addition to marvel comics he
really
didn't appear until 2013 after the mcu
started so clearly they were
building companion comics with what
they're gonna do the mcu oh wow
wow to think that marvel characters
started to be created
after the mcu began is such a weird
thing to think about yeah the membership
of the black order is different in the
comics there's like a fifth member
uh and there's some names that get
swapped around but his magic
doesn't have a whole lot of mythology to
it in the comics he's a whisperer which
allows him to control people's thoughts
and horses
now in the movies he's like telekinetic
he creates these like pointy shards to
torture strange but it's interesting
that he's not able to just kill strange
strange is pretty resistant and it
implies that
his eldritch magic and the protection
spell he put over the necklace
um trumps whatever kind of magic that
ebony mom can throw at him so either
he's too weak
at his magic or maybe it's not magic
like when i saw ebony i didn't
immediately go to like magic or sorcerer
of anything
i went to just like these are his
superpowers everyone's super powers are
kind of derived from from something else
though you know we don't have have too
many like hulks come from you know
science uh thor's comes from his own
science
iron man's comes from science so you
know maybe all the superpowers just come
from science
yeah science hey yeah it's possible i i
just think ebony mall has kind of a
sorcerer aspect to him
and functionally in the plot of infinity
war he's really mephisto
um mephisto is that kind of right hand
man to thanos in the infinity gauntlet
storyline um and then i think ebony
might even quotes mephisto's line from
the comics at the beginning of infinity
war
my humble personage
bows before your grandeur in infinity
gauntlet
mephisto doesn't even really get to be
himself he's just kind of like
there for someone to talk to for thanos
you don't really get to see his old
demonic background
in infinity gauntlet yeah they didn't
use him to his full extent which they
probably didn't need to use them to his
full next day no it's not about him yeah
so i would say ebony ma
it seems like he kind of possesses the
same sort of magic that the asgardians
do
it's somewhat cosmic maybe it's derived
from that ultimately though it's like
technological
it's it's bound by limits that the
sorcerer's supreme and even one of max
moff don't seem to be bound by
so this kind of brings us back to
scarlet witch versus doctor strange
because one division is showing us
wanda's god-level abilities
she can kind of create reality around
herself
uh and that's super scary from the
inside uh but it also
appears we think to be setting us up for
a showdown between
these two most powerful practitioners of
magic in the mcu
because we know she's coming back and
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and a lot of people think it's
going to be as a
as an antagonist figure to the sorcerer
supreme which
still the fact that doctor strange two
is coming out after
uh the next spider-man movie which i i
believe we're slated to have doctor
strange show up like that is official
right yeah so all three of these
properties are going to intertwine
all they want are answers and so far one
division is not giving me the answers i
need
god give me the answer nope nope nope
it's hard to compare
how powerful they are against each other
because it seems like their magic comes
from two different sources
yeah but we can look at the backgrounds
and the personalities of those using it
as we've been talking about so wanda
maximoff is kind of like the hulk with
her powers like
she's damaged she's out of control oh
they get stronger the angrier she gets
yeah exactly i mean sword uh is watching
her for that reason
sentient weapon observation and response
department ross labeled her a wmd
in civil war that whole sekovia accords
was about it took place right after
wanda
caused a lot of casualties in legos so
like hulk her power might be limitless
the limit does not exist but she can
only
be really uh contained and you know
she's containing herself in her own
little tv land her little nick at night
like uh why are they trying to bug her
she's happy yeah she's happy there um
and that kind of gives her an inherent
weakness the fact that she's not
totally in control and not totally aware
of what she's doing
compare that to steven strange stephen
strange is kind of like tony stark with
the way he uses magic
it's full self-awareness and uh
calculated
very calculated uh super efficient
surgical he's a scalpel right like
almost like they were both sherlock at
one point in time
yeah um he rarely wastes any kind of
effort he leaves very little collateral
damage in his wake uh we saw that in the
final battle uh in hong kong in the
doctor strange movie
he literally stitched back together that
city block
it's like my bad i can fix this yeah
we're good people are just like what
just happened we'll never know and they
live on with their lives whereas
you know scarlet witch leaves
destruction in her wake uh how powerful
is that
chaos chaos so to answer the question
while scarlet witch is more powerful
with her magic in the mcu
doctor strange is ultimately more
effective so if you were to think in a
conflict between those two
if that is indeed what one division is
setting up in multiverse of madness
i would expect strange to have the
advantage i would put my money
on doctor strange i would go the other
way and only because
let's look at a common denominator they
both fought thanos
dr strange did not win in that battle um
if not for the the blasts coming down
from the ship during the scarlet witch
and thanos fight
i think uh scarlet witch was gonna win i
think that she had him cornered and was
gonna beat him
so if one can beat thanos and the other
can't uh was that transcendent property
are you stupid or something i just think
that chaos magic because
it is unbound and uncontrollable that
he he's too precise he's too neat he's
too clean
and as soon as you have probability on
your side that that that's it it's
once probability is on your side
anything can go right in your favor and
against doctor strange so i'm
yeah i put my money on on on the chaos
magic
yeah you know that breaks up you bring
up a good point there jovin um
because dr strange does have this other
weakness we haven't talked about the
fact that he has his oath this
hippocratic oath of do no harm
when i became a doctor i swore an oath
to do no harm
and i have just killed a man i'm not
doing that again and
oh yeah kind of like you know the way we
see with batman how he can't ever hurt
anyone i will not kill
we could totally see that happen with
doctor strange his unwillingness to let
anyone get hurt
could be uh against him i have to
counter that with your uh thanos
argument well that is very true
uh scarlet witch almost wrecked him it's
almost like well
uh the patriots beat us earlier in the
season but we beat the patriots
so i mean we could beat you it's it's
almost like context gets shifted around
so much
you can't add sports logic into comic
book logic they don't
mix uh but let us know in the comments
below all of you watching and listening
uh watch your name the what's in it
doctor strange the watching we want to
hear from you whose uh
wizardry do you think is uh more
effective more powerful
and more useful in the mcu the way
they've been depicted because it's not
the same thing in the comics because
even in the comics
people's power levels and statuses get
shifted depending on what the
context of the story is anyway i i still
think that we're gonna see
comic book um scarlet witch really start
to like
come into the mcu starting now i i think
that's what we're gonna get
uh absolutely all right uh before we
move on to some questions that jovin's
gonna answer for us
uh we just want to shout out our merch
partners at epic hero shop
they are giving away 10 playstation 5s
people
it's an amazing opportunity you enter by
following their new youtube channel it's
called epic hero labs
it's crazy there's a lot of mystery
going on there and
then uh once you subscribe you fill out
the form at epicheroshop.com giveaway
and they will announce a new winner
every 10 000 subscribers they get
and speaking of these merch partners we
have a lot of great new rockstars merch
over there like the shirt i'm wearing uh
this is awesome those are so
dope unusual couple shirt uh yeah i've
talked about this a lot it's super
comfortable and it has like this ar
component so that
when you put your phone over it like
secrets and easter eggs start to pop up
in the floating consciousness here
it's it's awesome and this is a limited
in uh edition so we only have
certain amount of them once we only so
many secrets can go out that's right
that's right that's what makes it a
collectible
it's uh limited so you have to get your
hands on it uh
and you can go to newrockstarsmerch.com
or epic heroshop.com
both urls work any other urls don't work
um
and the good thing about doing this is
it supports new rockstars directly
uh we would love to get to a place where
we could just make the only way we have
to like
plug things is with shirts like this um
and uh
and you don't have to like have videos
interrupted with ads yeah on that shop
there's lots of great
different apparel not shirts there's
like hoodies uh onesies for your baby
dog clothes hats fur babies
yeah so go check all of that stuff out
at epiccaroshop.com
oh but another thing we want to tell you
about this episode is actually brought
to you by stereo who is helping us
launch
three new shows that will only be on
their platform
so stereo is a free live broadcast
social platform that lets people have
real conversations
in real time the app turns podcasts
into these fun two-way interactions
where listeners can record an
audio question or comment and send it
directly to
the show who will then play it and react
to it in real time
so it's like a podcast you can talk to
it's so freaking cool
and new rockstars is gonna launch three
new shows on stereo
including a sort of new rockstars news
show that's going to be me and phillip
on wednesdays where we're going to be
reacting to the latest news and taking
questions from you guys and goof around
kind of in the vein of this show a big
question but uh less researched it's
just going to be more like
what happened this week and talking
about less big brain yeah
uh and uh if you are a fan of the
editing style of big question you're
going to want to check out our new
monday show on stereo
editors read the comments where our head
editors john and joshua these are the
guys who put all the memes and funny
clips and a big question
uh they're gonna react to their favorite
comments uh in video moments from the
week so our youtube comments that have
all kinds of uh
direct pointed criticism they're gonna
explain whatever uh
get those comments in people yeah the
you might end up on that show
uh and then on friday mornings myself
and jessica clemons will be doing a live
inside marvel one division reaction or
typical after show
but there's gonna be a live component if
you join us on stereo you'll get this
way earlier then you'll see the video
version on
our youtube channel so yeah all three of
these shows are gonna be on the stereo
app so
download this free stereo app by going
to stereo.com
new rockstars so that you can connect
with us
whenever we are live and then stay tuned
for more details on how to engage with
us on stereo at the end of today's
episode
and then click on the link in the
description go to www.stereo.com
new rockstars to get started all right
uh jovan we have a few
bite size questions i'm going gonna
throw at you are you ready for it
i am ready to bs my way through these
answers i mean
answer these to the best of my knowledge
yup yup yup
all right so our first question comes
from mr mountain dew on discord
who asked how fast is an x-wing at full
throttle like the trench run by luke and
star wars a new hope they were in the
trench for a real long time
how did they escape the explosion what
was the time interval between
the blast fired and the death star
explosion
timeline speed and distance don't really
add up i need answers please
all right well i think to best answer
this i think we need to look at your
question
and uh remind you that when they were in
the trench run
they were not at full throttle first of
all uh
the the s coils were open so that means
that they couldn't be going as fast as
they possibly could go now don't get me
wrong we're about to contradict
uh that statement in a little bit and
it's it's a new hope's fault notice the
contradictions
when you play star wars squadrons you
can see cause you're controlling the
ships almost more like a sim
how fast you can go like what's your
normal speed and then how fast you can
go at a faster speed
um so i think when he was in the trench
run on it was there for a long time
because they're
okay here's the death star and they're
up here fighting but the
the porthole thing is down the exhaust
port is down over here
they want to draw all the firefight out
over here so that they can then go into
the trench
and then make it to the exhaust port so
they don't have to deal with as many
starfighters so that's why they were
traveling a large distance
not at full throttle now when you
re-watch the movie
yes uh first off let's look at this
other continuity problem
darth vader's like i have you now and
then shoots we see him shoot
and then comes in han solo with a yeehaw
and then like blast him out of the way
but like why didn't that blast ever get
luke skywalker like he hit
yeah it's a blaster it should have
gotten him right away
[Applause]
[Music]
now as for the flying away aspect we
actually do kind of have a cut where
like he threw it and then he flies out
and then we see him flying and then it
cuts away and then it cuts back to the
explosion and they're not there anymore
so
yes they should have still been in some
form of like
wave of that blast and when we do see
them flying away here's where the
hypocrite comes in let's discuss the
contradiction
the s-foils are open therefore they are
not flying as fast as they could be
flying
so they should have been rocked by the
explosion that's 100 true
but they can go supersonic speed x-wings
can fly
at super sonic speeds and that is how we
write this off
it was too fast
what position would the s-foils have to
be to jump in hyperspace which i know
they didn't jump in hyperspace in that
moment but
do they have to be closed just based on
friction alone i would imagine that they
have to be closed
and i think that there is footage of
them traveling at
uh at hyperspace closed so i think
that's they have to be closed but you
can still get the full throttle
you'll go fast but not as fast as you
can yeah i think the logic of the scene
was like oh well it took some time for
the proton torpedoes to create the chain
reaction
and we also don't know how long like we
see the radar like lining up with with
yavin 4 so we don't actually know how
long it takes to get that laser
fully powered so there could have been
some time during that hard cut
an excellent question and an excellent
answer our next question comes from
civilian
another friend of ours on discord who
asked in age of ultron it was confirmed
that cap
knew he could lift mjolnir but
intentionally didn't and that is why he
could summon mule near an end game
what other moments could cap have used
mjolnir that could have helped a ton
now this is a very fun question i love
this question
i'm going to kind of put the assumption
that
it was up to that point uh he he became
worthy
and maybe he wasn't even fully worthy
yet to lift it like
maybe he wasn't able to lift it lift it
but he was able to move it so he was
getting there
up until age of ultron or up until end
game uh at age of
ultron like okay i i think anything
before that
i'm gonna say that he wasn't worthy to
pick it up yet we're just gonna say that
just so you know let's look at all the
events happening afterwards
he gets off for um uh battle of new york
no blame there uh and any of the other
things that happened between battle of
new york and uh
and age of ultron i think winter soldier
came before
yeah so probably that's where he became
like worthy enough to be able to move
the camera yeah yeah
uh and so that when is because thor can
kind of travel around he's not always on
earth
so when thor and captain america are on
the same planet for him to be able to
utilize it would really only
been during the events of civil war
where the hammer would have been kind of
helpful the problem is
and this is canon yeah uh thor during
civil war
was in australia with no cell phone so
yeah so that's why he was never are you
insane
because of the commercial that he was in
or that short with this room
yeah he had no cell phone and he's in
australian
and so theoretically captain america in
his fight against
uh iron man could have maybe pulled
mjolnir then
but then thor would have showed up like
dude this is mine why'd you take my
hammer or like it's flying towards it
but then it flies away because like thor
wants it back he's like who took my
hammer
dude where's my millionaire so i think
that is the only time it might have been
helpful but again
we saw in avengers thor used the hammer
against iron man and it just fully
charged him so
he would just have to like maybe take
the hammer and like knock
down iron man and then just set the
hammer on top of him and that's how you
would use it to win that fight
you know it's like there were it was
implied that there were some battles
leading up to age of ultron right they
were kind of like they were tracking
down strucker with hydra
in all those battles thor was there and
you could argue that mjolnir was better
off than thor's hands than it was in
in cap's hands again being as humble as
he is probably at the same time
captain america wouldn't have wanted to
take his hammer away from him you don't
want to piss off the god
yeah and and there was a great collab
moment
in uh outside the sokovian base where
he's like all right let's do it and he
bashed the hammer to create that shock
wave like you need thor to come up with
those creative ideas when he has the
hammer in his hand if you just take the
hammer out of his hand
he's not going to ever eat any fish what
is he the god of hammers
yes that's not a bad guy to be
a thing to be a god
lots of hammers like you work at a ace
hardware or
home depot have a nice orange apron what
type of supplies you're gonna need i
don't know
a wood hammer
this next question comes from lance
pants on discord who asked
when and where could they have built the
peak space station at the end of
spider-man far from home assuming that
is the peak i think we're going to have
to start as far back as the
the the 90s once you know
uh nick crews kind of figuring out you
know outer space stuff
uh and let's look at a real world aspect
here to answer the question it's
probably like the iss the iss was not
built
on earth and then uh thrown up into
space it was actually built piece by
piece
in space so it was probably you know
under a bunch of different covert names
and whatnot
like sputnik probably like hated it or
no that wasn't that way too early but
you know
people putting up like satellites like
just a satellite it's like what's that
giant compartment attached like nothing
don't look at that
as they're flying up the space for for
sword to attach it to their uh to their
peak ship
so i think just over the course of 30
years it just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and it's kind of
used as a like the iss yeah that's a
great thought about the iss i didn't
think about that but yeah i mean they
you know they have cloaking technology
from the
scroll and from the degree so like they
just keep it all cloaked and it just
stays in orbit that whole time
and uh they hope no uh no other signals
get blocked whenever you have lose your
direct tv signal it's because the peak
yes yes and definitely not because
comcast sucks
three great answers there thank you jojo
i almost sounded like i knew what i was
talking about
no you totally did okay now we're going
to move on to our
question uh this one comes from mj on
discord
who asked have you ever had any movie
moments
in your life meaning something so
perfectly timed that it should be from a
movie kind of like are you living in the
truman show it's kind of what he's
asking
you know for me i'm based on
what i've done in my career i feel like
a lot of my life was
on camera and some moments were pretty
interesting i think one
that wasn't on camera that should have
been was
we had just finished uh filming the
series with microsoft
in in where we traveled in these really
expensive like quarter of a million
dollar cars
from italy through france down to spain
and at the very end we we had to like
get them back to
like the the car where it needed to be
and me and my driver
i didn't drive the car i had a
professional driver with me and
these it was a different team from uh
each part of the world so it was us and
then the german team
and so they had their guy and their
driver and we had to take our really
expensive cars that go really really
really fast
uh back to this location and this was
the first time in like the two weeks we
were traveling that people
weren't with us anymore so they just
they made those cars go as fast as they
possibly could
and we were just traveling through the
hills through like uh
through like their different highways at
uh we were going so fast
that i had g4 sickness when i got out of
the car i was like i'm gonna
no i'm good i'm good uh and i
that had to have been a movie like i
just feel like i was in a movie then
because
i not i would have died i had plot armor
essentially
yeah oh oh yeah lots of times we've had
plot i feel like every episode of big
question
we kind of one of the two of us tell
some story that was like
felt like we were in a movie i kind of
had like a spider-man far from home
experience when i was in high school i
went on a spring break euro trip
really um yeah but i did not you know
stop like um
uh elemental monsters in the video you
didn't have someone open up the
multiverse just to find out it wasn't
the multiverse around you yeah
right did not happen uh i didn't have a
billionaire mentor who gave me magic
glasses that's helped me
control drones um no but i either
sophomore
junior year of high school for spring
break we went to italy
and france uh we started in milan went
to venice
uh pisa sienna went up the uh was far
from post
because yeah yeah far from home and
really i wish we had only gone to like
just two of these places because you
can't really get a sense
of a place just for an afternoon i agree
um but then we you know you take a bus
up the italian coast and we went to
um monaco in nice and then took a bullet
train up to paris and
i uh was on this trip with a girl i had
a huge crush on
um it was just kind of like my mj and
you know you go on these trips and you
have these ideas of like
i'm gonna try to profess my love i'm
gonna get her a nice gift and
it's gonna be romantic because we're
gonna be in europe yeah literally just
crying this is great
yeah it was exactly the same thing and
then
um i uh wasn't having any luck i kept
getting grouped together with like the
wrong people
things you know i kept getting like oh
we with this group and they want to go
over here and i plans to meet up with
the same group she was in for like lunch
but then they ended up doing something
different
like we kept like not being around each
other or you know you try to get that
spot on the bus and try to sit next to
her but someone else you keep
disappearing to fight crime i did it
right
there was like a brad on the trip who
was like aware of it kept foiling me
um but then finally on like the last
couple days of the trip
um we were in paris and we went to the
louvre
and the louvre is not a very romantic
place uh
it's like an old dusty uh labyrinth
mansion
um that's crowded with her with tourists
um
but like we found a way i i was grouped
with her
and uh we ended up like wandering around
um the lube together and at one point
there's like a little bench in front of
this huge beautiful like
wall-sized mural of something uh
and then like our shoulders started to
touch a little bit
um and i was like it is happening and
then
that afternoon we went to versailles
which actually is a bit more romantic
they have some nice gardens it's like
the palace city and we
started to walk together and then we got
lunch
and she didn't have enough euros to
cover her so i covered hers
and then it was like out of nowhere on
the bus ride back to
paris she put her head on my shoulder
and i was like yes
that's the sign uh but that was the sign
i was so exhausted
that i started to fall asleep as well
and then i woke up when we got back to
the hotel in paris and she wasn't
sitting next to me anymore
but she wasn't really uh talking to me
for the rest of the trip and then some
friends
later were like laughing and they're
like i was like what is it and they
showed me they had
uh their their old digital camera video
that they had taken
i had leaned over and i was drooling
and she got up and moved and uh and i
totally blew it
and i feel like that's a scene out of
spider-man far from home right
oh my god i wish i i wish the writers
would have known that so they could put
that in the movie that should be in the
movie oh it's in my notes i'm going to
work it into a movie somewhere
yeah then all the parishes are like this
is stupid but he doesn't
have to keep his saliva in his mouth
until she asks for it
um but uh but crazy thing another like a
movie thing you think all is ruined
there was a third act danimata this
story
when like a month later on the other end
of it like the school year was ending
and uh another friend was like hey so
she
like so and so said like did something
happen with you guys in
in europe and i'm like yeah i made a big
ass myself they're like no she was kind
of expecting you to like follow up with
her
and i was like what i had already moved
on the whole high school conflict
they're waiting for the next move and
then we walk away thinking it's all over
i had no idea
and then summer break went on i had a
whole job that was
at a summer camp and i wasn't going to
see her be around town the whole summer
gotta
talk to the girl too late i
blew it i'm an idiot so i don't know
that kind of feels like a coming-of-age
thing
i could work that into a movie that felt
that that's that's the thing that's a
thing
that is a thing uh well hey jovan it's
been such a pleasure to talk matt
sometimes magic happens in your life
sometimes you miss the magic
and sometimes it's in dungeons and
dragons that's right
as of today february 2nd the first
episode of stuff of legends is out on
youtube.com
the jovenshire it is a show i am working
with wizards of the coast and dungeons
and dragons to make a
tabletop show that's uh laced with a lot
of puppet action so we play
dungeons and dragons with a group of uh
comedians and actors and all the
dialogue and action
uh is done by puppets so give it a watch
definitely give that a watch well joven
thank you again for uh joining me this
episode you can follow jovan at the
jovenshire on social media follow me at
ea boss follow me rockstar send us your
big questions using the hashtag
bigquestion
or uh join our discord by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
new rockstars all five of the questions
we had this episode were from our
wonderful patrons and that can be you
next episode
uh thank you subscribe to rockstars here
on youtube uh hit that notification bell
and another quick shout out to our
friends at stereo the app that lets
users listen in seek out topics and join
conversations about issues and ideas
that interest them like comedy pop
culture sports all kinds of topics
stereo can be downloaded for free by
apple and android users once you
download the app
you can create an avatar and profile and
start going live yourself
and you can submit audio messages to the
host of conversations to join the
conversation in
real time we'll be going live with our
interactive new rockstars news show
hosted by myself and philip on
wednesdays at 1pm pacific
you'll only be able to hear that on
stereo and you can submit your theories
and your reactions or your personal
grooming tips
on there catch our new shows only on
stereo every monday wednesday and friday
go to
stereo.com new rockstars to get all the
details and get notified when we're
going live
again that's stereo.com new rockstars
see you next week
bye
[Music]
you